good morning distinguished faculty
delighted family members younger
siblings playing flappy bird and the
distinguished class of 2014 this is
really such a remarkable day you are
graduating from an excellent school
today I can see it in your faces excited
full of hope and blissfully unaware that
you will be paying off high-interest
student loans well into your 60s I'd
like to give you some advice I mean it's
your commencement for crying out loud
you are about to run through the tunnel
onto an enormous field of uncertainty
you will take your lumps I can assure
you of that
but the only way you'll reach any height
in life and in love is by taking that
chance that you might fall you are ready
and able to do beautiful things in this
world you are unicorn
we are unicorns you have to get out
there and change the world change the
world be world changes yes you can apply
we want you to remember three things six
things 20 rules in no particular order
buck up or stay in the truck the hard
core never ever give up keep the flame
burning get rich do not make your name
important and you will embody what it
means for America to leave the world so
to the class of 2014
thank you congratulations your journey
has begun
you